Kann nur unter der Tür nicht durch, Wirbel,
Wirbel, ich will mit einem Aufrecht laufen, Wirbel, in einer Wirbel, Wirbel, ich will mit einem Aufrecht laufen, Wirbel, Knecht, Wirbel, Knecht, Wirbel, Knecht, Wirbel, Knecht, Wirbel, Knecht, Wirbel, Knecht, Wirbel, Knecht, Wirbel, Knecht, Wirbel, Knecht, Kann nur unter der Tür nicht durch, ja, du hängst an einer Wirbel, Wirbel, Knecht! Ein herzliches Willkommen zu dieser neuen ausgabe kommt rein setzt euch hin habt eine schöne zeit extra heute für euch mit dabei Stefan Tietze und mir dabei, er hat uns eingesungen und uns als Wirbelknechte beschimpft, Florentin Wöl. Guten Tag, danke und natürlich dieses Intro von Max, was mittlerweile entweder ein Gag ist oder wirklich jeder zweite Mensch heisst Max, ich weiss es nicht. Es heissen viele Max, es heissen viele Max. Alle da draußen lachen sich kaputt darüber, haha, er nennt mich Max, obwohl ich gar nicht so heiß, ich habe ihn nur so genannt, weil das der Running Gag ist. Das wäre ein fantastischer Witz. Das wäre wirklich Chefs-Kiss-Gag. Ich mag das Gefühl nicht, wenn ich das Gefühl habe, Leute ärgern mich und veräppeln mich und lachen sich hinter meinem Rücken scheckig. Wo kommt denn diese Kerbe her? Hast du da mal furchtbare Erfahrungen gemacht? Oh, da wurde ich mal hart erwischt. Nee, ich wurde geprankt, klar, wie jeder andere auch, natürlich. Aber so die letzten drei jahre freundschaft war ein prank der mag mich gar nicht mag mag mich gar nicht mag hat mich die ganze nur verarscht also wirklich so einem grossen scale dass du denkst hinter meinem rücken machen sich jetzt alle über mich lustig oder eigentlich nicht aber ich bin ja ein statistiker ich denke mir ja wenn das noch nicht passiert ist dann ist die wahrscheinlichkeit hoch dass es passiert. Also ich habe immer Angst vor den Dingen, die noch nicht passiert sind. Andere Leute haben sowas wie Traumata, da passiert schon mal was. Und dann haben sie Angst vor Milchshakes. Du sagst, wie blöd, ich habe keine Angst vor Krokodilen, weil mir nichts passiert ist. Wie blöd, mich muss ja nur mal eins beißen, dann habe ich Angst, aber dann bin ich trotzdem gebissen worden. Also hast du lieber Angst präventiv vor allem. Genau, Dinge, die mir schon mal passiert sind, die sind ja raus. Du wirfst ja nicht zweimal Zahl hintereinander. So, und deswegen will ich dir raus. Das ist wieder dein Roulette-Problem. Das muss wieder dein Roulette-Denk fehlen. Wenn Rot fällt, ist die Chance danach immer noch 50 für 50. Nein, nein, nein. Ich habe wieder viel Geld verloren im Casino. Grün ist eh die Null, also die sehr selten.
Kann man auf die setzen? Ist das so der klassische
Move von der Abifahrt, die dann sagt,
nein, ich setze auf die Null. Nein, das geht nicht.
Ach so.
Okay, dann auf die zwei.
Dann die zwei.
Von Null auf zwei, muss schon gerade sein.
Es gibt die, oh, die Null ist nicht gerade.
Ah, I don't know.
Thesen, wir hauen Thesen raus, die nur ein leichtes Schulter zucken. Ne, ich habe Angst, ich habe auch Angst, dass hinter meinem Rücken Leute Dinge machen, die ich, ähm, habe ich auch Angst vor, dass ich verarscht werde die ganze Zeit oder so. Aber bei mir ist es auch nicht empirisch, ich glaube, ich wurde auch zur Angst erzogen. Das stimmt, was mich natürlich geprägt hat, waren immer diese Mickey-Maus-Magazine mit Prank-Anleitungen und quasi eine ganze Generation Kinder wurden verführt zum Prank.
Da war dann irgendwie so... Die Bombenanleitungen aus dem Darknet in den 90er Jahren.
Genau, im Mickey-Maus-Heft war damals irgendwie auch ein Rezept für Napalm, wo du sagst, ja, jag deine Eltern mal einen Schrecken ein.
Und einmal lag er dabei, so dieser Plastiknagel. Jag deine Schule einen Schrecken ein. Die Acker. Und dann konntest du, und ich hatte den Plastiknagel, den konnte man so an so eine Scheibe machen, mit so einem Sticker, der aussieht, als wäre die Scheibe gebrochen, als steckte der Nagel drin. Und dann habe ich das bei meinen Eltern in der Küche gemacht, habe ich so eine Vitrine mit so einer Glasscheibe, habe ich das angebracht, habe ich mich auf die Lauer gelegt, nach fünf Minuten habe ich es nicht mehr ausgehalten und habe es wieder abgemacht. Das ist der lameste fucking Prankster, den ich jemals gehört habe. Aber er hat von mir gehört. Ich saß da und dachte mir, oh, die werden sich so kreuzärgern. Und dann dachte ich mir, nee, das kannst du nicht machen, das kannst du nicht bringen, das kannst du nicht bringen.
Das war dir zu weit, aber weisst du noch das Gefühl, war es, es war berauschend, es war berauschend, war es das Gefühl, nee, das unmittelbar, bevor du es abgenommen hast, war das Gefühl, ah, das ist, meine Mom kriegt einen Herzinfarkt, war es ein, das ist auch ein bisschen lame, ehrlich gesagt, zum Vorbein. Nee, nee, nee, es war viel zu, das ist zu extrem gerade.
Das ist zu extrem.
Das ist so, wenn eine Comicfigur, so ein Amboss an so einer Schnur hängt über der Tür und dann sich denkt, Mann, das tut wirklich weh. Also nochmal, das tut dem Roadrunner, wirkt also ernsthaft weh. Da wollte ich mit dir sprechen. Wir haben uns ein bisschen hochgeschaukelt gegenseitig. Ich wollte nur sagen, der Roadrunner würde vielleicht sterben, wenn ein Ambus auf ihn fällt. Ja, aber letzte Woche haben wir versucht, ihm eine Rakete um den Hals zu binden und ihn auf den Mond zu schießen. Klar, aber da haben wir auch schon gesagt, kurz so. Weißt du noch, als wir einen kurzen Moment hatten, wo wir dachten, ah, ist das zu viel mit dem Mond? Um ganz ehrlich zu sein, als am Ende die Rakete dann nicht losgeflogen ist, als die Lunte zu Ende gefahren war, ich war ein bisschen erleichtert. Same! Sorry, ich muss es auch mal sagen, ich war ein bisschen erleichtert. Und das Klavier, das wir aus dem Flugzeug geworfen haben, dass das so um ein Haar an ihm vorbeigeflogen ist, ich war kurz erleichtert. Macht es nicht Spaß, dass wir ihn fast umbringen? Stell dir vor, ich verstehe, was du meinst, ich verstehe, was du meinst, ja, ja, ja. Stell dir bildlich vor, dass du die Guillotine, die du das letzte Mal gebaut hast, dass die ihm wirklich den Kopf abschneiden, weil er hat
Kinder.
Ich habe einzelne Kinder mal
kennengelernt, ja stimmt, das ist so,
was ich mir auch letztens gedacht habe, vielleicht ist
es für uns eher die Jagd
und gar nicht so sehr das Erwischen,
also dass wir, ich glaube, hätten wir
Roadrunner wirklich erwischt, wir beiden Koyoten,
dann hätten wir, glaube ich,
hätten wir, glaube ich, echt ein Problem,
weil vielleicht müssten wir dann unsere persönlichen Probleme auch mal angehen. Hast du das Gefühl, dass wir vor unseren Problemen weglaufen, indem wir uns komplett auf das Morden des Roadrunners konzentrieren? Ich glaube, wir rennen ihm hinterher, um uns nicht miteinander zu beschäftigen. Glaubst du, er rennt aber auch gerne vor Dingen weg? Er rennt auch vor was weg, ja klar. Weil er ist auch nicht zu Hause bei seiner Frau und kümmert sich um seine Kinder, sondern er lockt uns quasi und rennt weg. Du, als ich das einmal mit seinem Sohn gesprochen habe, meinte der auch so, Papa ist nie zu Hause, der kommt nie zu Hause und dann, der ist ja sehr gut versichert, also der muss ja wahnsinnig gut versichert sein. Klar, da muss viel Geld reinfließen. Also also da gibt die unglaublich viel Geld aus. Komplett Papiergeld frei, aber trotzdem natürlich viele Versicherungen schlucken viel Geld und die haben wenig zu Hause. Aber ich glaube, das ist letztens, was die ganze Welt am Laufen hält. Jeder rennt vor irgendwas davon und deswegen rennen alle. Weil das ist auch gut, weil ansonsten, wenn alle irgendwie, sonst wäre es eine Art von Stillstand. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe meine Familie
schon lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Auch hinter uns die ganzen Ambosse
und so und diese
Bazooka hinter dir. Ich meine, es ist schon
Ja, es ist schon viel.
Herein. Oh nein, der Amboss!
Oh nein! Oh nein, er ist tot!
Oh mein Gott!
Überall Blut.
Überall das ganze Blut.
Warum hast du mich letztes Jahr nicht zu deiner Geburtstagsparty
Vielen Dank. Oh mein Gott. Überall Blut, überall das ganze Blut. Warum hast du mich letztes Jahr nicht zu deiner Geburtstagsparty eingetragen? Da drüben ist ein anderer Roadrunner. Was ich mich frage, Blutenvögel, weil ich habe mal gelesen. Was auch immer ich da überfahren habe, es hat geblutet. Du hast eine Taube überfahren, du musst es uns eigentlich sagen. Kein Blut. Ich hab an meinem Auto, an den Reifen, nichts. Vielleicht war es eine Tontaube. Vielleicht war es keine echte Taube. Stimmt, es hat Knack gemacht, also wie so ein, es hat das Geräusch gemacht, wie als hätte ich eine Tontaube überfahren. Das erklärt auch, warum sie nicht weggefahren, Flo Rung. Nee, ich... Fahr doch, Mensch! Krüter wird's nicht! Boah, du gib mir Gasto! Die Tau. Ich habe damals mal Wellensittier gehabt und dann stand vorher in diesem Vorbereitungsbuch, was man lesen muss, bevor man sich Wellensittier anschaut. Du hast nicht nur das langweiligste Haus der Welt, sondern du hast davor auch noch ein Buch gelesen. Sie wollen also einen Vogel, der fliegen kann, in einen Käfig sperren? So geht's. So geht's. Machen Sie sich die Gedanken darüber, denn das ist ein Tieres und eine grosse Verantwortung. Das ist unfassbar grausam. Überlegen Sie sich, ob Ihnen das das wirklich wert ist. So, und da stand drin, dass Wellensittiche zwei tropfen blut in ihrem körper nein das macht es natürlich auch umso beeindruckender dass sie regelmäßig blut spenden das ist eine richtig krasse Aktion das macht das erhebt die für mich wirklich noch mal diese Art von Tiere dass die so wenig haben und trotzdem geben. Die geben, geben, geben. Und wir 90 Liter Blut und geben fast nichts ab. Fast nichts ab, wollen wir gar nicht. Wir bestehen fast nur aus Wasser und Blut. Aber zwei Tropfen heisst es, wo sind die zu welcher Zeit? Also hat der ein Tropf im Kopf und der andere kreist so rum oder wie ist das? Das ist ein bisschen wie ein Traum, den ich neulich hatte, an dem ich leider darüber nachgedacht hatte. Das war ein komischer Physiktraum. Also irgendwie, der Traum war irgendwie abstrakt, alles war sehr klein, klein, klein, ganz klein, Puppenhaus klein. Und da war so eine ganz, ganz kleine Miniaturflasche. Also stell dir vor, das Miniaturwunderland in Hamburg und stell dir vor, dann ist da so ein feiernder St. Pauli-Fan und der hat eine kleine Bierflasche in der Hand. Das ist eine ganz runtergeschrumpfte Flasche und im Traum habe ich mir die Frage gestellt, kriegt man da überhaupt Wasser rein oder ist die Mindestgrösse eines Wassertropfens? Okay, jetzt müssen wir natürlich noch eruieren, wofür steht die Flasche, wofür steht das Wasser? Was versuchst du irgendwo reinzukommen? Und was war der Traum? Der Traum war nämlich wirklich, dass ich mir Gedanken gemacht habe, ob da überhaupt Wasser reinpasst oder ob das Gefäß zu klein ist. Gibt es eine Mindestgrösse für Wasser? Das ist eine gute Frage. Du hast ja diese Wassertropfen und ich kenne immer nur diese ganz kleinen Schnecken. Es gibt wahnsinnig kleine Schnecken. Die sehen aus wie eine Nacktschnecke, aber sind wirklich winzig klein. Und die ja trinken. Und dann siehst du auf dem Blatt, siehst du so ein Wassertropfen. Was für uns die geringste Anzahl ist. Genau, was für uns kaum einen jemanden sättigen würde, wenn man Durst hat. Nee, es ist auch direkt die geringste Einheit, Wasser kommt in den Tropfen. Ja, und dann kommt diese winzige Schnecke und will diese Wasserblase trinken, aber in dem Moment, in dem sie die berührt, wird sie komplett eingeschlossen von dem Wasser. Und das ist wirklich, die kommt dann, die ist ja wahnsinnig langsam und irgendwann so ist sie komplett eingeschlossen. Und ich denke mir, vollidiot. Im Namen des Wassers, ihr gebt uns Geräusche, weil wir sind ja ein mächtiges Element. Ja, ja. Genau, aber das Geräusch, was sie uns geben als Menschheit, ist weil Feuer ist zum Beispiel ja genau, genau, genau. Oder Luft. Ja, und selbst ein Erdbeben, also so Erde ist auch irgendwie krass. Ja, genau. Nur weil wir als Wasser ja auch irgendwie cool sind und auch... Ja, ich... Also, vielleicht kann man sich was gegenüberlegen, wie so eine Flut, wie so ein Wasserflut. Nee, das sehe ich nicht. Okay, und Sie sprechen für alle Menschen. Ich habe den einen Menschen angesprochen, ich als Aquaman. Sie haben ja jetzt mich angesprochen. Also ich habe jetzt, ja, ich kann jetzt nur für mich sprechen, aber ich finde das durchaus passend, weil Wasser ist zum Beispiel das langweiligste Getränk, wenn jemand sagt, ah, du willst abnehmen, okay, trink Wasser, so trink das, was so gar nichts macht, was dich so gerade am Leben hält.
Ich hasse es auch, Aquaman zu sein.
Ja?
Ich mag Wasser auch nicht. Kannst du nicht eine Umschulung machen oder so?
Cola Man.
Kannst du nicht irgendwie da was zum Earth Man oder Feuermann, gibt es da eine Möglichkeit?? Earthman. Oder ist es wirklich so eine... Das klingt eine fucking Band aus den 70ern. Also was hast du in der Ausbildung gemacht? Oder ist das ein Studium oder wie kommt man da rein? Ja genau, das ist ein Volo. Also man macht so ein Volo und dann... Wie lange dauert das jetzt noch? Das ist jetzt noch zwei Jahre. Zwei Jahre noch. Und dann wäre ich Aquaman of Art, also Bachelor of Art. Okay. Und kannst du danach nicht irgendwie gucken, ob du dann irgendwie so Quereinsteiger mässig. Da kann ich irgendwie Master noch machen, irgendwie als Feuermann, aber da weiß ich nicht genau, ob die einen nehmen, weil man halt Wasser war, aber ich glaube, es ist irgendwie auch freie Berufswahl und so. Du, ich würde dir empfehlen, mach das jetzt erstmal zu Ende. Also mach das, denn hast du was, sondern hast du was in der Hand? Jedes Gespräch auf einer Party, ever, ever, können wir aufhören darüber zu reden. Aber ich finde es eine valide Frage, ob so eine ganz winzige Flasche, ob da was reinpasst. Eben. Also ob da wirklich. Oder ob das dann nicht dann sozusagen, keine Ahnung, Bullshit, vermutlich Bullshit, aber ob es mehr Energiekosten würde, die Luft daraus zu bekommen, als Wasser reinzumachen oder so, keine Ahnung. Ich meine, es ist wirklich so, wir lachen ja regelmäßig über Christen und so, von wegen ha ha ha, von wegen Gott hat die Welt erschaffen. Wie dumm. Aber wenn man sich jetzt mal ganz, also ja, ich weiß, wir lachen gerne, Stefan, wir lachen, Stefan, beruhig dich, beruhig dich. Stefan, beruhig dich, wir lachen, ich weiß, ja, ich weiß, wir haben immer viel Spaß, worauf ich hinaus will. Ja. Wenn man sich die Welt anguckt, kann man nicht doch ein bisschen das Gefühl haben, dass sie schon auf den Menschen optimiert ist? Weil für diese winzige Schnecke, die ja Wasser trinken muss, aber der Wassertropfen so gross ist wie sie selbst, die denkt sich, in was für einer fucking Welt lebe ich denn, was soll das denn, wir Menschen, Flüssigkeiten, wunderbar, geht Luft zum Atmen, gute Höhe. Ja, man sagt ja, gut, wir sind auch angepasst, genau auf den Planeten. Ein Schnecke ist ja auch angepasst. Ein Elefant ist auch angepasst, aber er ist halt viel zu schwer für alles, was passiert, braucht unfassbare Mengen Wasser, findet er kaum. Ich verfolge ja so ein bisschen dieses Kreationisten gegen Evolutionstheorie, da gibt es ja viel Internetkampf und so. Und dann ist immer so, dann machen sich natürlich die unglaublich vernünftigen Leute darüber lustig, was für dumme Argumente die Kreationisten haben. Ein Argument ist zum Beispiel, naja, guckt euch mal die Banane an, die ist genauso gross, dass sie in die Hand passt von Menschen, also muss das ja alles intelligent design mässig gemacht werden. Und da lacht man natürlich laut drüber. Kaputt. Aber so ganz falsch finde ich es nicht, weil die Banane ist wirklich perfekt. So, jetzt die Wassermelone ist ein bisschen zu groß. Aber ja, okay, aber ich meine die Banane wurde von Menschen. Und waren die Banane nicht viel kleiner. Genau, die wurden von Menschen natürlich so hingewiesen. Also wir leben ja nicht in einer kreierten Welt, sondern wir schaffen uns die selber. Aber trotzdem, ich meine, da ist ein Henkel dran, du hast eine Schale. Ich meine, sorry, aber das ist halt schon wirklich optimiert für uns. Also wir haben schon Protagonist-Energy, oder? Auf jeden Fall. Also Menschen haben schon fucking Protagonist-Energy. Stell dir vor, du bist eine Katze und du fängst eine Maus und denkst dir, ach guck mal, da ist eine Batterie drin. Ach guck mal, die Maus, die rüttelt so hin und her, genauso wie ich es mag. Und die wackelt genau so, dass ich hier hinterherlaufe. War verrückt. Guck mal, ich habe hier die Maus gefangen, da war eine Batterie drin. Ach so, nee, das ist halt eine Maus mit Batterien, aber genau.
Ach so, das ist schon verrückt, weil die ist halt genau, also die wackelt, die genauso wie ich es mag, das ist schon verrückt.
Das ist schon genauso wie ich es mag, das ist schon krass.
Also, meinst du nicht, ist es so eine Art, also ich weiss, du bist ein sehr vernünftiger Hund. Wir können hier offen reden. Wir können hier offen reden. Hund? Ja. Ja, wir können, okay. Und du bist sehr an Wissenschaft interessiert und so. Ja. Und wirklich vernünftig. Und du schaust auch immer so alte Carl Sagan und so, Harald Lersch. Aber meinst du nicht, ich meine, die ist so perfekt für mich gebaut, die Maus. Meinst du nicht, es gibt was Größeres hier? Du meinst, dass die Knochen, die sie mir hinlegen, die flauschig sind und so. Keine Knochen sind, sondern irgendwie. Von welchem Tier? Welches Tier hat diese Stoffknochen? Ich dachte, der Dinosaurier Barney oder Samson aus der Sesamstrasse. Wenn der Knochen hat, sind die flauschig. Heinrich, wir haben letzte Woche darüber schon gesprochen. Barney existiert nicht. Ah ja. Okay? Ah ja, ich bin Hund. Du erinnerst dich? Ich erinnere mich kaum. Ja, du hast keinen? Kaum. Kaum. Ich erinnere mich an Gerüche, aber nicht an so Fakten. Ah, okay.
Du meinst, mein Knochen ist gar nicht von einem Tier, sondern für mich zugeschnitten? Ich glaube, ja.
Von den Menschen?
Schau mal, das Halsband, das du um den Hals hast, da steht Heinrich drauf.
Was ist denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass auf dem Halsband genau dein Name draufsteht?
Also genau so, wie du heisst.
Kannst du denn nicht, da steht, meinst du nicht, dass da irgendwie mehr dahinter steckt? Du argumentierst kreationistisch? Ich weiß, dass du das nicht magst, dass du da wieder genau deine Gegenbeispiele bringst mit der Wassermelone. Aber du verrennst dich manchmal in diese komischen Ich hab manchmal so Phasen. Genau, weißt du noch die Phase, hast du Angst, dass du vor Gurken und so? Ich meine, es ist einfach albern, du bist manchmal so Phasen gefangen.
Ich will nur sagen, du tippst wahnsinnig kreationistisch und ich finde das irgendwie weird.
Lass uns nochmal das Huhn fragen.
Und das Huhn ist so ein cleverer Gelehrter.
Mit dem Esel sprechen wir nicht mehr. Wir sind in die Bremer Stadt.
Ach so, das war die ganze Zeit der Plan?
Ja, okay, wow. Weird, also ganz Crossover hätte ich nicht gebraucht, aber niemand hätte es gebraucht. Aber ja, ich bin ein grosser Fan von Crossover. Ich habe heute auf dem Weg hierher eine junge Frau gesehen mit einem Pullover an und da waren die vier Häuser Hogwarts, so klassisch mit den Farben und so, in diesen, also wie so ein grosses Wappen, das so geteilt ist in vier Teile und in den einzelnen Partitionen waren dann aber nicht die Tiere von den Hogwarts-Häusern, sondern Pokémon. Und irgendjemand saß an einem Tisch und hat gesagt, welches Pokémon passt zu Slytherin? Und da dachte ich mir auch, gehen wir zu weit? Sind wir zu weit? Nee, nee, nee. Sollen wir nicht nochmal einen Schritt zurück? Du meinst gegenüber der Pokémon oder du meinst generell als popkulturelle Gesellschaft? Ich habe die junge Frau konfrontiert. Ja. Ich habe sie konfrontiert und gesagt, entscheide dich. Zieh dir das schön aus! Entscheide dich. Ich weiss, du bist Fans von zwei Dingen, aber du kannst ja auch zwei Pullover an zwei Tagen tragen. Und außerdem, Herr, der Ringe steht genau daneben und hört zu. Und welches Pokémon war es Slytherin? Naja, erstmal die Frage natürlich. Du hast ja die vier Pokémon. Welche vier?
Naja, die Schiki, Bissasam, Jumanda und Pikachu. Und plötzlich merkst du, alle süss, nett.
Nee, aber du merkst auch, die Farben passen perfekt. Jum Bizaram für Slytherin.
Bizaram ist Slytherin, aber das finde ich passt auch ganz gut, weil der immer so ein bisschen der Böse. Shiggy ist so ein bisschen der lockere, coole, gut, der passt jetzt auch nicht zu Ravenclaw, aber dann natürlich noch als vierter Gelb Pikachu Hufflepuff. Also dafür, dass es nicht sein soll, dass es wieder der göttlichen Natur ist und es wirklich in mir intensivste Ekelgefühle hervorgeholt hat, passt es dann doch sehr gut. Und da denke ich mir wieder, meinst du, das ist Zufall oder passt es nicht, dass es nicht genau so dazufast? Das sind die ersten vier Farben, auf die jeder kommt. Komischerweise sind es auch die Häuser von Game of Thrones.
Du hast immer eine Erklärung.
Komischerweise sind es genau die Häuser von Game of Thrones auf.
Targaryen, ja, perfekt. und ich werde dir auch noch ein Suits rein. Packet, wir packen Suits mit rein. Und Seinfeld.
Seinfeld hat vier Figuren, ja.
Ja, genau.
Perfekt.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Also die vier Figuren Seinfelds.
Elaine, Jerry, Kramer und George.
Kramer ist Hufflepuff.
Kramer ist Hufflepuff, George ist Ravenclaw, Jerry ist Gryffindor, Protagonist, und dann Elaine Slytherin? Schwierig.
Ja, schwierig. Ich glaube, du kriegst jedes Franchise irgendwie so hin. Also es ist gefährlich. Aber fände ich eigentlich auch gut, ein Pullover mit einfach allen Franchises der Welt. Wie viel kriegt man da rein? Aber wo wir gerade bei Kreationismus waren, ich habe nämlich gedacht, also es ist eine Theorieorie in der ich noch arbeite, ist eine Arbeitstheorie aber stell dir eine also es ist ja nicht so unwahrscheinlich, dass es irgendwo da draußen auch noch mal intelligentes Leben gibt in diesem grossen Universum und weil es ja nicht unendlich gross ist, aber schon fucking gross, gibt es wahrscheinlich auch mehrere. Da muss ja nur, wir sind ja auch schon sehr weit, wenn man sich anguckt, wie sich unsere Videospiele verändert haben von 1990 bis jetzt. Ich meine, ich gucke gerne bei Twitch Leuten zu, wie sie Rollenspiele spielen, also wie sie sich einen Charakter ausdenken und den für, weiß nicht, vier Monate lang, sieben Stunden am Tag, spielen die diesen Charakter in einem echten Umfeld. Und die ganze GTA-Map ist bevölkert von anderen Leuten. Angenommen, die Zivilisation erreicht irgendwann einen Punkt, wo man alle Krankheiten einigermaßen besiegt hat, diese ganzen Bottlenecks wie Überbevölkerung, was auch immer, die alle überwindet, an irgendeinem Punkt altert man nicht mehr oder es wird super alt, Krankheiten spielen keine grosse Rolle mehr, man langweilt sich doch einfach zu fucking Tode und dann würde man doch genau, weil diese Exhibition ist ja natürlich jetzt auch schon tausend Jahre weiter als wir, die haben doch noch krassere Spiele. Die spielen doch dann wirklich Rollenspiele. Und das sind wir. Das ist meine These. Wir sind... Also du kombinierst eine Alien-Theorie mit einer Simulationstheorie. Die Alien simulieren uns. Aber nicht Simulation. Aber wir werden gespielt. Also ich werde auch quasi von einem Stefan-artigen Menschen gespielt. In dieser sich langweilenden, weit entwickelten Zivilisation steht jemand an einem Computer, also so ein VR-Ding und spielt mich. Okay, ich finde... Ich lebe hundert Jahre hier als Stefan. Das ist für den gar nicht viel. Das ist so ein Level, so einen Charakter halt und dann fängst du einen neuen an. Ja, und du spielst so fünfzehn. Finde ich gut, ich glaube nur, dann hätten wir aufregendere Leben. Weil, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, kurzer Einblick in mein Privatleben, ich sitze am Rechner. Und die Vorstellung, dass irgendwie Sorgmorph der Aliens sagt, oh geil, ich spiele heute wieder Erde, ich habe meinen neuen Florentin-Charakter, meinen Podcaster Level 12, logge mich ein und dann sitze ich am Rechner. 14, komm Level 14. Naja, okay. Ja, nee, komm. Naja, das gebe ich dir. Naja, danke. Und dann sitzt er am Rechner. Also ich weiß nicht, es geht darum, dass du ein möglichst gutes Leben führst, mit möglichst viel Spaß, äh, etc. Ähm, und ich glaube nicht, dass dann, und vor allem, du kannst jetzt auch nicht durch die Gegend sausen, äh, wie Superman oder sowas, oder kannst Leute umbringen oder spielst irgendwie so ein, weil ich bin ja auch, ich werde ja auch gespielt, das heißt, du musst das ganze Jahr, wenn du siehst, diese, diese Rollenspielserver bei Twitch haben wahnsinnig viele Regeln. Du kannst da auch keinen Serienmörder spielen, weil das halt von allen alles kaputt machen würde. Die ganze Spielerfahrung, ich glaube, genau so ist es. Ja, aber es gibt ja Mord in unserer Welt. Also was ist denn da der Mörder? Der ist dann so ein Cheater oder der wird dann sozusagen von den Admins. also das heißt eigentlich immer. Also das heißt eigentlich immer, weil oft ist es ja bei Rollenspielen auch so, dass man sagt, ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf den Charakter, kannst du mich umbringen, damit wir das noch irgendwie gut zu Ende bringen, damit ich nicht einfach verschwinde. Ist es dann auch so, dass sich diese zwei Aliens absprechen und sagen, du, ich hab meinen Charakter verskillt, irgendwie, der kann nix, der ist irgendwie, ich würd gern neu anfangen, kannst du mich nicht umbringen? du mich nicht umbringen? Und das sind dann Serienmörder.
Ich glaube, die können nicht reden. In meiner Theorie haben die alle
so eine Kappe auf
und werden künstlich ernährt
für hundert Jahre lang, wie sie uns spielen.
Du schlüpft einfach
in ein anderes Leben.
Einzige, und ich würde
sofort sagen, ja genau so ist es,
es ist viel unwahrscheinlicher, dass es nicht so ist,
als dass es so ist. Und die Plotline aktuell ist, irgendjemand spielt dich Und dann ist es auch ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, viel unwahrscheinlicher, dass es nicht so ist, als dass es so ist. Ja, und
die Plotline aktuell ist,
irgendjemand spielt dich
und spielt, wie du die Idee
hast, wie es tatsächlich ist.
Also so wie wenn ein Pen-and-Paper-Charakter
sagen würde, sag mal,
könnt ihr euch nicht vorstellen, dass irgendwo in einem
stickigen Keller fünf Leute sitzen,
mit so Blättern vor sich und
uns spielen, mit so Werten auf so einem Blatt Papier.
Na, irgendwer in der
Sohn-Milation hat ja auch Matrix gedreht.
Also die Wachowskis sind ja auch,
werden ja auch gespielt von
Aliens. Also die Wachowskis haben aber
Matrix gedreht, haben es aber nicht hinbekommen, selber
dann weiterzudenken.
Und sie haben es auch verkackt.
Also sie haben ja nicht meine Theorie
herausgefunden.
Also vor allem meine grösste Frage, sonst würde ich sofort sagen, genau so ist es, ist, wer sind dann meine Eltern? Aha, okay, die wurden dann auch gespielt. Weil wir sind ja schon die Produkte unserer Eltern. Ja, es ist ja oft so, dass man, wenn der Charakter irgendwie langweilig wird, dass man ein Kind von dem weiterspielen kann oder so, aber dann würde man ja aufhören, die Eltern zu spielen. Das heißt, bei dir werden ja gleichzeitig NPCs interessant. Ja, ja. Das heißt, ein Bots. Eher sowas wie Boomer-Bots einfach. Die werden dann einfach, die alte Generation wird durch Boomer-Bots ersetzt und dann spielt man die nächste Generation weiter, bis wir ersetzt werden. Und noch die andere Anschlussfrage ist, ist es hier gerade materiell oder Simulation? Und da bin ich doch bei materiell. Gibt es da eine Hotline? Ich weiss nicht, an wen du dich da wenden kannst, aber bleib mal dran, es ist eine interessante Theorie. Das Problem ist natürlich, du kannst ja, also du kannst dann gar nicht selber entscheiden, was du machst. Das heißt, als du die Taube überfahren hast, aber du bist nur jemand Schöne. Ja, aber du bist nur jemand anders, der dich spielt. Ich spiele mich. Und das Ding ist, das gibt mir auch jetzt mal wieder Kraft. Aber du weißt ja nicht, dass du dich spielst. Du bist ja du, ohne dass du das Wissen hast. Nur über jemand spielt ja meine Sachen entsprechend seines oder meines Denkens. Wir teilen uns ja einen Kopf. Und deswegen denke ich mir, alle Sachen, die ich entscheide oder sowas. Ich habe damit so ein bisschen meinen Frieden geschlossen, wieder, weil ich dachte. Dieser selbst ausgedachten Theorie. Ja genau, weil wie cool ist es, wenn man dann stirbt. Man ist ja noch da, also man ist ja, man findet zwar mein körperliches Ich, aber ich bin trotzdem noch der Geist. Fängst deinen neuen Charakter an und dann machst du nochmal einen Zauberer oder sowas. Ich finde die aber super sinnvoll, die Theorie, weil angenommen es gibt gen unendlich strebende Zivilisationen im Weltall, da muss ja nur eine davon sozusagen so weit sein und dann wäre die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wir in so einer Simulation sind, wenn die das denn können, wenn die bis dahin gekommen sind, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit schon viel grösser, dass wir das sind, als dass wir es nicht sind. Ja, kann gut sein. Kann natürlich auch nur sein, dass du eine Ausrede suchst, um dich diesem Taubenmord zu entziehen, dass du sagst, das bin eigentlich nicht ich, euer Ehren, sondern das ist das Alien, das mich steuert eigentlich. Ja, das Alien hat diese Taube umgefahren. Ich frag mich nur, ist das unterhaltsam genug, weil können wir gerne eine neue Folge machen von Florentins Haushalt und kein Jingle und Florentins Haushalt.
Rappadadadada, rappadadadada, dinglelingleling, Florentins Haushalt.
Ja, nach meinem Abflussdesaster kommt jetzt die neue Staffel. Florentins Haushalt. Also es war noch lange in der Verhandlung. Oh, das freut mich, danke. Wir haben lange verhandelt, soll es noch weitergehen. Wie geht es mit den Figuren weiter? Und jetzt tatsächlich haben wir grünes Licht bekommen. Es gibt eine neue Staffel und zwar Badewanne. In der neuen Staffel wird sich alles um die Badewanne drehen. Und ich habe ja schon mal erzählt. Kürzen wir zeitlich genau da an, wo wir aufgehört haben? Genau, wir fangen genau. Oder Zeitsprung. Nee, wir setzen genau in der Szene an. Das war uns wichtig. Sind wir in der gleichen Wohnung oder es ist Anthology? Nein, wir in der gleichen Wohnung, es wird genauso fortgesetzt, mit welchen Figuren, aber es gibt ein paar Twists, also haltet die Augen offen. Und ich habe ja vielleicht mal erwähnt, dass mein Badewannenwasser nicht so heiß war, lange Zeit. Und ich bade gerne, ich bin gern Bader und deswegen habe ich tatsächlich auch teilweise mit dem Wasserkocher nachgeholfen, was unfassbar erbärmlich ist und wahrscheinlich nichts bringt. Und ich habe tatsächlich, während der Wasserkocher geblubbert hat, stand ich mit einem Papierzettel an meinem Schreibtisch und dachte, wie rechnet man das jetzt aus? Bringt es was bei einer 200 Liter Badewanne, die keine Ahnung, 40 Grad hat, ein Liter auf 100 Grad zu erwärmen dann hast du so zwar die namische 200 liter 40 grad ein liter 100 grad und dann habe ich versucht diese zahlen zusammenzudrücken mit reiner muskelkraft habe ich versucht diese zahlen einander zu pressen ich habe das blatt in der mitte zusammenaltet. Oder einen Bleistift reingesteckt. Und versuch die zusammenzudrücken.
Funktioniert nicht.
Jetzt ist das Wasser wieder fucking heiß.
Und deswegen geht es mir unglaublich gut, weil ich heiße Bäder wieder nehmen kann.
Mir geht es richtig gut.
Ich habe mich gestern fast verbrannt.
Ich lag wirklich in der Badewanne und dachte, ich bin gleich durch.
Ich bin gleich so richtig Schweinchenpink durch einfach.
Ich bin durch.
Und grossartig, aber Problem, der Dreher vom Abschlussstöpfel ist abgebrochen. Das heißt, das Wasser fließt nicht mehr ab. Es fließt nicht mehr ab. Es fließt nicht mehr ab. Das heißt, wenn ich einmal bade, war es das. Ich habe einen Bad. Stimmt nicht ganz, weil ich habe herausgefunden, ich kann mit einem Schraubenzieher unten den Stöpsel so raushebeln. Das heißt, ich habe jetzt immer, wenn ich bade, einen Schraubenzieher dabei. Das heißt, ich habe immer einen Schraubenzieher zur Hand, sodass ich immer... Dein Gurkenglas, ein Schraubenzieher, es werden mehr Dinge, die du hast. Mehr Accessoires. Und jetzt habe ich einen Schraubenzieher dabei und muss manuell immer den Stöpsel raushebeln. Okay. Das ist aktuell die Staffel. Das heißt, dieses... Es fängt locker an, es fängt locker an. Diese hoch entwickelte Alienwelt, wo Raumschiffe herumfliegen und so, Leute reissen an der Lichtgeschwindigkeit herum. Du musst dich vorstellen, und das unterstützt die These auf eine Art auch, die haben so eine Langeweile in ihrem, es gibt nichts mehr zu, alles wurde gesagt, alles wurde herausgefunden, die haben keine Krankheiten mehr, die spielen lieber dich. Genau, wie ich rot und fett und schwitzend in der Badewanne sitze und irgendwo zwischen meinen Beinen mit dem Schraubenzieher. Gürtchen, noch ein Gürtchen, Gürtchengeist im Mund gefunden. Im Badewasser gefunden. Und dann wieder an die Arbeit machen mit dem Schraubenzieher. Und währenddessen sitzt er so vor seinem Rechner. Okay, hier, komm mal, kriegt er das hin? Warte mal, was war denn das nochmal? Shift-S? Command-Aplus-A. Warte mal, ich mache das Menü auf. Gürkchen. Was ist das Handtuch? Das ist eine Lesebrille, ganz weit unten. Gürkchen, aha. Und hier, wenn ich jetzt... Benutze... Erika, was passiert, wenn ich hier auf den Schraubenschlüssel klicke? Benutze Schraubenzieher mit Abfluss. Meinst du das, klar? Schrauben, aha. Ja, geht. Ja, der macht's auf. Der macht's auf. Und das Wasser fließt ab. Okay. Ja, kann sein. Ja, auf eine Art kann ich mir das genau vorstellen. Weiß ich nicht. Okay, aber das heißt, du hast das Problem gelöst, du kannst wieder heiß baden. Ja, was heißt gelöst, ich habe eine schwierigere Möglichkeit gefunden, das zu tun, aber keine Ahnung, wie man diesen eigentlichen Dreher, mit dem man den Korken aufmacht, wie ich den wieder anbringen soll, deswegen liegt der mal eine Heizung, das ist ja Scheisse-Familie für dich, weil die kennen sich damit aus. Die frage ich und die bringen dir einen neuen Nübel rum. Einen Nübel für den Hubner. Okay, ah, Nübel für den Hubner. Ja. Okay, für den, er müsste, er müsste hinten den Hubner aufdrehen. Nee, du musst den Schlonsch reinmachen, damit der Nübel den Hubner hochmacht. Ach so, okay, ich dachte, der Hubner drückt den Hubner aufdrehen. Den Schlonsch reinmachen, damit er den Hübner hochmacht.
Ach so, okay, ich dachte, der Hübner drückt den Hübner runter.
Er will.
Ach sorry.
Und deswegen lassen wir das Profis machen. Ja, okay, ihr habt recht, ihr habt recht. Ihr seid teuer, aber gut.
Genau, hey ja.
Hey ja.
Hey hell yes.
Genau, also das ist doch gar nicht so schwierig, glaube ich. Also du brauchst um neun.
Aber mich freut das wieder. Frage, wie viel Produkt machst du in die Badewanne?
Fünf Sekunden.
Fünf Sekunden Produkt?
Fünf Sekunden Produkt. Was ist so ein spezielles Schaumbad?
Es ist irgendwie so, ich glaube, jeder hat ja so Quatschticks im Kopf oder so irgendwie obsessive Dinge, wo man sich denkt, das ist nicht so schlimm. Aber immer, wenn irgendwo Wasser läuft oder so, zähle ich Sekunden mit. Immer. Wenn ich einen Wasserhahn aufmache, zähle ich mit, wie lang der läuft. Wenn ich irgendwie meine Wasserflasche unterm Wasserhahn befülle, zähle ich die Sekunden mit, wie der Wasserhahn läuft. Du bist so verrückt. Du bist crazy es ist super, aber alle sagen das. Ich weiß, es ist super langweilig, aber es ist einfach so ein Ding, ich weiß nicht, woher das kommt, aber ich zähle das einfach immer mit und deswegen hat es sich bei mir auch etabliert, dass wenn ich irgendwie was fülle, also irgendwie dieses Schaumbad in die Badewanne, zähle ich mit, wie lang das läuft. Fünf Sekunden ist recht viel, aber ich mag es auch schaumig. Aber kannst du das Produkt verraten? Also kannst du die Marke verraten? Ja, absolut, das ist Alpiflor Latschenkiefer. Alpiflor Latschenkiefer. Alpiflor Latschenkiefer. Das sind die besten. Was ist das für eine Kiefer? Latschenkiefer, Latschenkiefer, das sind die besten. Es ist so, als würdest du ganz tief in so einem moosüberwachsenen Baumstumpf liegen, um dich herum zwirbeln die Zwirbler und die Nadelbäume senden ihren einladenden Duft. Alles, was an dieser Flasche sagt, Gartenprodukt, finde ich. Ja, das ist auch ein richtiger Prügel. Bei dem Gartendünger.
Das ist auch ein richtiger Prügel.
Also diese Flasche ist ein Prügel.
Hat so eine Manufaktum-Ästhetik dazu?
Also sie ist so wahnsinnig so altdeutsches Tante-Emma-Ladenprodukt aus, was immer noch den gleichen Chef hat seit hundert Jahren. Absolut. Alle sagen, Herbert, du kannst jetzt mal irgendwie das ganze Geschäft an deinen Sohn abgeben. Nein, ich habe den Wald und jeden Tag ziehe ich einen Baum raus und schiebe ihn in die Presse rein und dann kommt das Alpiflor Schaumbad raus. Das macht er seit er Kind, seit er acht Jahre alt ist. Seit er acht Jahre alt ist, hat er diese Firma. Okay, kostet Rossmann, ne gibt's nur in der Filiale, gibt's keinen Preis. Tausend, ein Liter ist da drin. Und ich kaufe auch da immer vier, fünf Flaschen von. Also das ist, wenn ich einmal zu Rossmann gehe, dann gibt es Grosseinkauf. Dann nehme ich da vier so dicke Flaschen mit, auch ohne Rucksack, das ist mir wichtig, ohne Rucksack trage ich die so in der Hand, so wirklich in der Hand, also fünf Flaschen. Hast du das auch manchmal, wenn du was trägst, dass du dir denkst, ich könnte jetzt angeschossen werden und würde es vielleicht überleben.
Also ich habe manchmal so, wenn ich irgendwie so eine Kiste, so einen Mini-Ofen vor mir her trage, denke ich mir, wenn ich angeschossen werde und also, ich wünsche es niemandem, toi toi toi, aber wenn dann jetzt, Also ich denke auch so, wenn ich da so ein Buch abhole oder sowas vom Packstation Amazon, denke ich mir so, wenn ich genau jetzt hier angeschossen werden will. Es gibt ja immer so die Geschichten, dass jemand angeschossen wird und dann hat er die Bibel und da ist dann die Kugel drin oder sowas. Du hingegen mit der Bibel bei Audible auf den Ohren. Genau, ja stimmt. Das wäre mal eine geile Werbung für physische Bücher, so für meierische Buchhandlung oder halt einfach die Bib halt einfach Okay, aber wie sieht die Werbung aus? Also jemand hört
die Bibel auf dem Kopf, wird umgeschossen
und sagt, hätte er doch die Bibel
physisch in der Tasche gehabt, hätte sie vielleicht
die... Meiersche Buchhandlung. Genau.
Die Werbung hat es selber ungeduldig.
Ja, ich bin ungeduldig.
Meiersche Buchhandlung.
Mein Gott. Hätte ich die
Bibel doch physisch meiersche Buchhandlung.
Also man kann sich den Rest ja auch dann denken.
Aber es stimmt jetzt keine schlechte Bewerbung.
Du, es sind bestimmt schon viele Leute
nicht gestorben, weil sie iPhones oder
Handys irgendwo hatten, dass dann die
Kugel umgeleitet hat und die Batteriesäure
dann ihnen das Herz weggeätzt hat
oder was auch immer. Du stirbst dann langsam und
schmerzhafter. Gut, aber später.
Diese seltenen Erden in deinem Körper, wo
ihre Reaktionen aussehen. Todesursache, seltene Erden. Ich bin gegen seltene Erden allergisch. Es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, Problem im Alltag. Zum Glück. Gott sei Dank. Gott sei Dank. Nee, geht mir schon auch so. Ich wäre noch nicht fast erschossen worden.
Oh, weil ich bin mit dem Fahrrad einen Weg gefahren, den ich häufiger fahre, in Köln über die Fendor-Strasse und plötzlich war da überall Polizei, überall und ganz viel Krankenwagen. Und dann, ich war so zehn Minuten danach, nachdem es passiert ist wohl, bin ich vorbeigefahren.
Und dann war ich so eine Stunde unterwegs, bin wir zurückgefahren, immer noch alles voll und die Polizei hat so Riesenzelte auf der Strasse aufgebaut. Und wirklich ungesehen, so Polizeipavillons. Und dann musste ich das grossartig, grossräumig umfahren, grossartig umfahren. Und dann habe ich gelesen, es war eine Schießerei. Es gab eine Schießerei auf der Fennlors-Strasse, eine Rockerbandenkriege. Es gab eine Massenschlägerei, da sind zwei Schüsse gefallen. Alle Menschen sind auseinander gelaufen und in der Mitte waren noch irgendwie zwei der beteiligten Leute irgendwie angeschossen. Ich glaube, beide sind über den Berg, sind dann ins Krankenhaus gekommen. Grüße gehen raus. Naja, ich glaube, es sind schon Hardcore-Kriminelle. Okay, ja, aber naja. Naja, Genesungsgrüsse gehen raus. Besserungsgrüsse. Ja, eine bessere Empfehlung geht raus. Rehabilitationsgrüsse gehen raus. Mit Sternchen. Bitte nicht nochmal machen. Bitte nicht mal machen. Und die lagen dann da rum. Und dann wurden diese ganzen Zelte nur dafür da, um halt Spuren zu sichern. Das war auch sehr stürmisch und dann wollten die glaube ich so ein bisschen, nicht dass da noch einmal die Patronenhülse weggeweht wird. Die komplette Fenloer Strasse und dann ja, oh nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Meinst du, sie haben deswegen die Schiesserei
an dem Tag gemacht, weil sie wussten, heute ist stürmisch,
heute werden die Spuren verwischt,
weggeweht, der Wind ist unser
Freund, als Rocker bist du ja eh immer mit dem Wind
im Einklang, und dann einfach
die beiden Rockerbanden kommen aufeinander.
Wir haben Recht, wir tragen blau.
Wir haben Recht, wir tragen rot.
Du bist nicht, gar nicht so schlau, denn ich bin ein Rock im Blut. Ich meine, es ist extrem gewalttätig und furchtflössender anzusehen, aber die Musik ist super. Fantastisch. Also die Musik bei so Rockerkriegen sind gut. Aber vor allem, also ich denke jetzt, wenn du sagst Fenloer Strasse, denke ich direkt an Kebabland, da ist ja direkt gegenüber die Polizei. Genau, es war unweit. Also die ist ja wirklich nicht weit weg. Unweit des Kebablandes. Ist das denn so schlau, direkt in der Nähe der Pilze? Da. Harald, machen wir ein Blaulicht an oder brauchen wir das? Das ist ja direkt um die Ecke hier, Mensch. Das ist doch Fenloer Kebabland. Da lässt er das Licht aus, aber jetzt auch. So und da ist er direkt hin, ist er natürlich auch unklug, ne? Ja, na ja, weiß ich nicht. Sie haben auch nicht die Täter gefunden oder sowas, also anscheinend war es nicht. Ach so, bei einer Schießerei? Ich dachte, die Täter sind dann schon, haben sich gegenseitig erschossen im exakt gleichen Moment. Ich glaube nicht, ich glaube, das sind einfach die beiden. Es wurden Schüsse abgegeben und die beiden hat es halt erwischt. Okay. Nicht zwangsläufig, die die Waffe getragen haben, aber weird, wild, ich fand das richtig wild, vor allem ich wohne in der Nähe und dann ist man plötzlich in so einem Schiessereigebiet, was man hier selten hat. Ja. Also in Deutschland glaube ich nicht so viele Schiessereien, wenn man das vergleicht in anderen Ländern, wo es dann vielleicht häufiger mal es nicht mehr dann in den News mal mehr schafft. Dieser Inzident hätte es in Amerika nicht in den News
geschafft. Und hier war es
einfach auch in den Tagesthemen abends.
Und es war halt sehr nah an mir dran.
Trotzdem habe ich keine Angst weiterhin vor
Rockern. Du hast keine Angst vor Rockmusik?
Ne, ich höre immer noch
Rockmusik.
Wenn die Kneipe ist und da ist Rockmusik,
da hast du ja nicht Angst um dein Leben, sondern sagst, ja man,
geil.
Also ne, hab ich keine Angst vor. Da hab ich auch knallhart.
Wo in der grossen Rangliste der Verbrecher würdest du Rocker ansetzen?
In Deutschland glaube ich auf Platz eins.
Aber vom Coolness her, also ich weiss nicht.
Ach so, du meinst die grosse Top 5 der Schwerkriminellen. Ja, bei True Detective gab es auch eine gruselige Rocker-Szene. Die fand ich dann schon ein bisschen creepy. Das stimmt, die waren gruselig, ja. Aber sonst hast du recht, die nicht so, also Mafiosi haben halt so mehr ähm Ja, ich finde es halt komisch, dass sie sich so über ihr Hobby definieren. Wir sind Rocker, wir mögen Motorräder. Ah, Kriminalität, so, das weiss ich nicht, das hat so was wie wenn so der Pokémon-Fan-Club dann auch noch kriminell wird, irgendwie so, das ist so, wir haben angefangen, come for the Rock-Musik, stay for the shootings. Mit Aerosmith und sind geblieben für Drogenhandel. Ja genau, das ist so ein Hobbyklub irgendwie, wir werden so Kegelvereine, auch Kriminelle.
Ja das Miniatur Wunderland, also solche Leute.
Ja genau, die sind auch schwer kriminell, Modellbauer.
Modellbau-Club.
Ja, es gibt kein anderes Hobby, wo man...
Heute Berlin in Neukölln kam es zu einer Schiesserei, der Modellbau-Club in Neukölln hat sich gewehrt gegen den Kegel-Club Ösyrthe West. Fünf Tote. Fünfhunderttausend Tote. Es wurden sechstausend Schüsse abgegeben, allerdings aus sehr kleinen Pistolen, die allerdings in Kombination absolut tödlich waren. Denn man muss sich das so vorstellen, wenn selbst wenn ganz kleine Schüsse immer auf
die gleiche Stelle treffen, frisst sich das durch. Deswegen gab es sehr viele Tote. So kleine Wild West. So kleine Panzer. Ja, also du hast recht, es ist ein bisschen komisch, dich über das Hobby zu definieren oder so ein Lifestyle. Aber die Rockerbanden sind in Deutschland vor allen Dingen, also ich glaube, am Trasten für Drogen zu sein.
Also kein Problem, nee, nicht, macht es nicht, bitte keine Kriminalität.
Bitte, mein Wunsch für das Jahr 2024 ist, bitte keine Kriminalität. Wenn ihr im Begriff seid, ein Verbrechen zu begehen, bitte denkt kurz an mich und denkt an mich, wie ich traurig auf meinem Sofa sitze. Und nur sagst, bitte keine Kriminalität. Du sagst nicht warum nicht. Du gibst nicht viel.
Keine Begründung, keine Strafe, keine Macht, keine Umsetzung, sondern einfach nur bitte keine Kriminalität. Denkt an mich, wie ich dadurch traurig werde. Ich werde dadurch traurig. Warum? Du sagst auch nicht warum. Na, weil ich will, dass Leute zu Schaden kommen. Okay. Also bitte, wenn man die Steuer hinterzieht, als jemand, der jetzt nicht mega reich ist. Ja, der Fiskus, du denkst, du vergisst immer den Fiskus. Der Fiskus hat auch Gefühle, okay? Bist du traurig beim Fisk? Ja. Also wenn ihr es am Ende dann doch macht, okay, aber denkt zumindest einmal kurz an mich und denkt daran, dass es mich wirklich unglücklich macht. Ja, okay. Denkt an Florentin, wie er mit seinem Schraubenzieher in eine Badewanne sitzt und versucht, die aufzubekommen, während ihm Gurkenreste aus dem Mund fallen, ins Badewasser, das kocht, das mittelkocht. Ja, ich meine, 2024 wird vielleicht das Jahr der Gerechtigkeit gegen Verbrechen, aber es wird auf jeden Fall auch ein Modejahr. Selbstverständlich! Es wird ein Modejahr, vor allem natürlich für euch, ihr habt die Chance, denn... Vor allem dank euch auch. dank euch auch dank euch von euch für euch ihr habt es ja mitbekommen der community merch drop wir haben angekündigt wir haben das fäschernetz ausgeworfen daraus in die community
und wollten ganz viele tolle designs haben weil wir gemerkt haben ihr seid einfach auch besser
im gestalten und kreativ sein als wir. Und deswegen haben wir das euch überlassen. Ganz uneitel haben wir gesagt, na dann macht es doch ihr. Und ihr habt ganz viele tolle Designs eingesandt. Und daraus haben wir ein paar ausgesucht und jetzt einen tollen Merch-Drop zusammengestellt, den ihr noch, Achtung, bis Ende des Jahres bestellen könnt. Danach nie, nie, nie wieder. Das ist ein limitierter Drop, ein zeitlich limitierter Drop. Danach gibt es diese Motive nicht mehr. Nie wieder. Es sind sechs Motive und ich möchte danach nicht die Frage lesen, kann ich das noch irgendwo bestellen? Nein. Ja. Nur bis Weihnachten. Gibt es vielleicht für mich noch irgendwo eins? Nein. Nein. Vielleicht ja, aber eigentlich nein. Nein. Vielleicht liegt da noch irgendwo was rum. Ja. Ja, aber es soll jetzt nicht einreißen, diese Frage soll nicht einreißen. Ja. Weil es soll nur produziert werden, was bestellt wird. Dafür muss man so Wellen machen, Jobs machen. Und wir wollen das Ganze ein bisschen zeitlich limitieren. Keine Angst, danach gibt es wieder tolle Sachen. Genau, es gibt den Standard-Merch mit Logo und alles gibt es immer. Aber diesen Community-Drop, den Logo, den könnt ihr auf jeden Fall nur bis Ende des Jahres bestellen.
Schaut einfach mal vorbei bei podcast-ufo.fail, schaut euch das an, auf Reddit findet ihr einen Post, Instagram überall, nichts zu übersehen und dann könnt ihr bis Ende des Jahres noch entscheiden, ob das was für euch ist. Und die Pufo-Club-Mitglieder unter euch, die kriegen 10% Rabatt, natürlich auch auf diesen Job, bittet uns dafür in eurem Patreon den richtigen Link. Den habe ich da rein gepostet, dass ihr da auch klarkommt. Generell alle haben eine gute Zeit im Clubhaus. Wenn ihr Bock drauf habt, rumzukommen. Es ist immer noch Bowle da. Dann könnt ihr uns sehen. Wir haben einmal am Anfang eine Riesenbowle gemacht und tatsächlich solche Schüsseln haben mehr Volumen, als man denkt. Man denkt immer, oh, das geht weg, aber das geht nicht wirklich weg. Nee, diese Bowlingschüssel ist immer die Bowlingschüssel, die ist richtig voll. Aber wäre doch auch cool für eine Party, oder? Man trinkt aus Bowlingkugeln, man hat so Flüssigkeiten, weil sind Bowlingkugeln innen hohl, weiss niemand, was für Dinge da drin sind, Löcher hast, nein? Nee, du kannst das in Lö, aber ist das nicht ekelig, aus den Löchern zu trinken, wo die ganze Leute reingrabbeln? Ja gut, aber du hast halt eine Kugel mit drei Löchern. Das heißt, du kannst drei verschiedene Getränke gleichzeitig haben. Ja, aber dann trinkst du aus einem und dann kommt es aus den anderen beiden auch raus. Boah, ich finde das nicht gut. Aber warum hat sich das nicht durchgesetzt eigentlich? So mehrfach Gläser, aber so mehrfach Gläser. Du hast ein Glas, einfach mal so eine Sektflöte mit in der Mitte noch so einer Abgrenzung drin und dann hast du einerseits. Und oben so einen Klappdeckel. Ja, Klappdeckel. Und dann kannst du aus einem was trinken und aus dem anderen trinken. Ja, genau, umklappen, finde ich eigentlich ganz gut. Weil, also ich bin ja natürlich Freund von, sag ich mal, aufregenden Getränken wie einer Vanilla Coke, aber ich mische auch gerne Wasser dazu. Also ich erfinde jetzt das Getränk mit der Ecke und wir haben so eine, da ist so ein kleines Reagenzlas drin mit Vanille. Also du hast eine Coke, stell dich eine Coke vor und da drin ist so ein kleines Überkopf Reagenzlas mit Vanille und man kann an so einem kleinen Drehrad außen kann man dieses Reigenzlas öffnen
und, ach vielleicht ist das auch
wie so eine Mühle, weißt du, und man kann
drehen und immer neue Dosen
Vanille rein, Vanille sekret
rein machen
mit Arbeit noch
an dem Wording, ich will nur, aber streng
genommen wissen Sie, wie ist es Sekret,
wir müssen es so benennen, wir müssen es Vanille-Exkremente
Wir dürfen es nicht Nektar nennen, deswegen müssen wir es Sekret nennen, leider ja. So, dieses Vanille-Sekret kannst du dann so rausschaufeln mit dieser kleinen Mühle. Genau. Und die Gravitation hilft, die hilft uns da. Zum Glück würden die sich auch noch gegen uns stellen, neben dem Gesundheitsamt. Das Finanzamt, das Gesundheitsamt und die Gravitation gegen uns arbeiten. Das würden wir nicht stemmen können. So, dann kämpfen wir auf vollerne Posten. Aber dann kann man es so runterdrehen. Das Getränke heißt das Podcast-Ufo? Dominipatris Sanctus! Der Herr findet's gut. Danke. Ihr hört die Glocken nicht, aber sie sind in eurem Herzen. Das erinnert mich daran, dass ich ja letzte Woche gefragt habe, ich glaube schon zwei Wochen her, ich glaube schon drei. Das war letztes Jahr. Die Zeit rauscht an mir vorbei. Ich kriege das nicht in den Kopf, diesen Gedanken. Aber ich habe mich gefragt, was trinken eigentlich Priester? Was ist im Messwein drin? Gerade bei der Kommunion. Bei der Heiligen Kommunion wird ja auch offen, vor allem draus oben getrunken, in evangelischen Zirkeln, Sekten, ja sogar alle. Irgendwie gibt es dann wirklich so ein Abendmahl vorne, was so nachgestellt wird, das steht mir ultra langwierig vor, aber auch katholischen Priester haben dann immer diesen Wein vor. Ich habe mich gefragt, ist das ein guter Wein oder ist es so ein Aldi-Tetra-Pak? Turns out, nee, es ist tatsächlich, also ich habe verschiedene Quellen, die einen, die mir geschrieben haben aus der Community, vielen Dank an euch, da hies es schon eher, das ist ein guter Wein. Also es muss gewissen Qualitätsmaßstäben entsprechen. In Deutschland wäre es halt so typische Prädikatswein, VDP-Wein. Es ist natürlich irgendwie schwierig, das auf der Welt zu normen, weil andere Länder haben verschiedene Qualitätsstufen für Wein und es ist nicht immer alle gleich. aber im Deutschen ist es dieser VDP Wein, der da genommen wird.
Der Vater einer mir nahestehenden Person möchte ich nicht Geschlecht gar nicht sagen, weil es ist, wir haben einen Whistleblower, ein Fahrer sogar
und der sagt, der billigste
Billigweisswein
Weisswein auch noch
Hä, warum?
Blut Gottes, Jesu, Blut Okay. Und der sagt, der billigste Billigweisswein, Weisswein auch noch.
Wir haben gesagt, Blut Gottes, Jesu, Blut Jesu, er hat gesagt, das spielt gar keine Rolle. Weisswein.
Aber warum muss es dann auch noch Wein sein?
Genau, es könnte nicht einfach Cola sein oder Traubensaft oder so. Traubensaft.
Also da will ich ja, ich finde, da ist eine Coke Cherry näher an Blut Gottes als Weisswein.
Weisswein, ja. Also das ist ja völliger Unsinn.
Alban.
Völliger Unsinn.
Das war's. Also da will ich ja, ich finde da ist eine Coke Cherry näher an Blut Gottes als Weisswein. Weisswein, ja. Also das ist ja völliger Unsinn. Albern. Völliger Unsinn. Plasma, das Plasma Jesu, Blutplasma, das auch durchsichtig. Das Hämoglobin Jesu. Es gibt so viele Sekten, in irgendeiner gibt es bestimmt das Hämoglobin-Sekret Jesu. Ich finde es jedenfalls merkwürdig, es wird nicht so richtig, aber anscheinend dieser dieser Weisse Wein scheint auch nicht so schlecht zu sein. Also wahrscheinlich zieht sich durch einigermaßen mit so einem Prädikatswein. Es ist also kein Billigwein. Da gehen also, da gehen eure Kirchensteuern hin. Ist aber gut, auch mal was zu trinken, während so einer langen Predigt und Rede, dass man einfach mal so was trinkt, dass man das in so ein Ritual einbaut. Und dann sprach Resum Hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hmrocknete Früchte, Vanille, Eiche ein bisschen ich, jawohl. Hm, oh.
Was sind denn jetzt die letzten zwei Gebote, Vater?
Hm, hm.
Wir haben schon acht, was sind die letzten zwei Gebote, Vater?
Psch, ja, oh, im Nachgang auch lange am Gaumen.
Hm, oh, das ist wirklich, das ist wirklich fantastisch. Du sollst nicht was? Was war das? Sie haben mitten im Satz aufgehört.
Hm, hm, hm, ah, wow. Das ist wirklich fantastisch. Du sollst nicht was? Was war das? Sie haben mitten im Satz aufgehört.
Wow.
Bisschen Heiliger Geist im Abgang, ja.
Ja, gut.
Können wir den Schnaps rausbringen? Heiliger Geist?
Himbeergeist gibt's nämlich.
Es gibt immer Geister, ja. Warum gibt's den Heiligen Geist nicht?
Oh, ich glaube, da haben wir Copyright technisch ganz schwer.
Da kommt der Vatikan und sagt, Freunde, Freunde, Freunde, Freunde,
Heil, Lord, ich verklage euch.
Also da glaube ich haben wir ein Problem.
Ich glaube, mit der Kirche willst du dich nicht anlegen.
Die sind mächtig, die haben Artefakte, die haben Reliquien.
Gegen wie viele Schweizer Gardisten könntest du kämpfen? Drei schaffe ich, aber vier wird schwer. Ja, man unterschätzt die, glaube ich. Na, die sind ja nur in der Masse stark. Drei schaffe ich? Also die Schweizer Gardisten, ja. Also null bis zwei, kein Problem. Null sind glaube ich überhaupt kein Problem. Null glaube ich sind geringes Problem. Und dann eins bis zwei ja, okay, aber ich glaube, drei kriege ich noch, aber ab vier wird es schwer, weil die natürlich auch ausgebildet sind, in der Gruppe zu kämpfen. Deswegen, glaube ich, sind die individuell eher schwach. Da bin ich eher überlegen, weil ich bin eher ein individueller Kämpfer. Ich bin nicht so gut in Gruppen, aber dafür kann ich einzeln sehr gut kämpfen, auf jeden Fall. Ja, super. Okay, gut, alles klar, dann haben wir also ich würde so machen ich mache einen flickflag über den ersten und haue ihm von hinten gegen den kopf aber das ist doch nie ein flickflag jemals geschafft aber in naja du vergisst das adrenalin nicht ich glaube in der situation wenn ich in die ecke gedrängt werden also ich stelle mir vor ich im vatikanischen archiv ich versuche die reliquien zu klauen um die finanziellen hast eine Cola mit reingesagt, keine Cola im Vatikan, du sagst, doch, ich will die Cola behalten. Ach nee, ich dachte, wir sind in so einem Katakomben so. Ach schon, weil du hast doch nie geklaut in deinem Leben, aber jetzt geht es in diesem Beispiel ... Ich dachte, wir müssen die Reliquien klauen, um das Geld zu haben, um den Streitfall zu gewinnen mit dem Anwalt. Mit dem Heiligen Geist. Ja, genau, wegen Heiliger Geist. Und dann glaube ich, mache ich einen Flickflack über den Ersten, trete mit dem Knie hinten gegen den Kopf von dem Ersten, der fällt um, dann schnappe ich mir die Waffe von dem, drehe mich so schnell ich kann. Die anderen beiden denken, oh nein, wir müssen was machen. Und wo ist er? Ich sehe ihn gar nicht, weil er sich so schnell dreht. Ich drehe mich so schnell, die werden ungeduldig, die warten 20, 30 Minuten und denken, wann hört er auf zu wirbeln, weil wir können nur erst angreifen, wenn er aufhört zu wirbeln. Wirbel will. Aber ich höre nicht auf zu wirbeln, ich wirbel weiter die ganze Zeit, solange es sein muss. Nach 20, 30 Minuten werden die ungeduldig und denken sich, okay, jetzt kommen, gehen wir rein, greifen wir an. Ist ein langes Warten für einen Kampf. Es ist ein langes Warten, aber du kannst ja so eine Texttafel einblenden oder so, das kriegen wir hin. Das ist die Realität. Und dann sagen die, okay, jetzt haben wir lange genug gewartet, jetzt greifen wir an, gleichzeitig, und dann greifen die gleichzeitig an, rennen direkt in meine Waffe rein, und ich hau die sofort kaputt. Das war sehr convenient, also dass die genau beide... Ich wirbel ja, ich drehe mich ja so schnell ich kann. Ja, das hast du noch nie gezeigt, dass du das kannst. Das ist ja schon ein krasser Skill. In dem Moment kann ich, glaube ich, wachse ich in mich hinaus. Adrenalin, nimmer noch Adrenalin. Ich nehme diese Hellebarde, die sie haben, drehe mich ganz schnell, und die vervieren die Geduld. Woher ist die Hellebarde her? Mein Vorteil ist, ich habe in dem ersten habe ich die abgenommen, die mich von hinten während dem Flickflack und Knie gegen den Hinterkopf getreten haben. Aber die sind ausgebildet wahrscheinlich, auch in so einem Martial Arts oder sowas. Nein, das glaube ich nicht, das will ich auch nicht, aber ich will auch mal den Flickflack sehen. Wenn ich den Flickflack oben drüber, die können gar nicht nach oben gucken, so. Ach, das ist das Ding? Helle Gardisten können nicht wie Hunde gucken nicht nach oben. Wie Hunde und Schweine und helle Badisten und Gardisten. Das weiss doch jeder. Das war so süss. Der kleine Hund in meinem Leben, den es gibt, der liebt Vögel. Also sein grösstes Ziel ist mal jemals, mit dem Vogel zu fangen. Und dann plötzlich bin ich mit dem rausgegangen und dann über uns, es wäre wie ein Wunder Gottes, flog so die Wildgänse, so Wildgänse in Richtung Süden. Und der ganze Himmel war voller Wildgänse, die, und er hat dieses Geräusch gehört, weil die sind ja extrem laut, weil es sind tausende Vögel und die haben alle gequakt und er war so amazed von diesem Geräusch, aber er hat nicht nach oben geguckt. Und ich habe ihn nicht dazu bekommen, nach oben zu gucken. Und wie der grösste Idiot habe ich da hoch gezeigt, als würde er verstehen, was das bedeutet. Dann habe ich selber nach oben geguckt, aber er hat nur mich angestarrt und verwirrt, wo dieses Geräusch herkommt. Dann habe ich mich neben ihm gekniet, damit ich auf seiner Höhe war und habe auch hochgeguckt. Und ich habe es nicht hingekriegt, dass er jemals nach oben guckt und selbst wenn, die haben auch keine guten Augen.
Du musst ihn so packen und so aufstellen wie so ein Pappbecher.
Wie so eine Rakete, wie so eine Neujahrsrakete.
Ja genau.
Aber ich verstehe, aber und dann guckt er hoch und er hat keine guten Augen und das so diese zwei, diese kleinen schwarzen Punkte an diesem hellen Himmel, ich glaube, das würde er auch nicht sehen.
Das ist eine Schitshow und ich war so, ich war so aufgeregt und fand das so toll, da wurde der Hund so aufgeregt, aber ich war, ich konnte ihm das Wunder nicht zeigen, und dann, vor allem die Zeit läuft ja auch ab, weil die fliegen ja nur so lange über dich. Ja, ja, große Scheiße. Das heißt, der Hund fragt sich jetzt ständig, was ist da passiert, wo sind die hin, wo wollen die hin, muss ich denen helfen, was ist los? Aber die Welt ist schon trister, wenn die Vögel weg sind, wenn die Ententeiche leer sind, die Gänse weg sind. Die Tümpel, die Ententeiche leer. Die Tümpel sind leer. Einfach leer, so du sitzt alleine da, wirfst den Toast vor dich. Die Tümpel sind leer, die Teiche verlassen. Der Sumpf verlassen, sturmfreiem Tümpel. Das Leben ist jetzt woanders. Das Leben ist jetzt im Süden. Ja. Nicht mehr bei uns. Und ich stelle mir, ich habe mir diese Kindliche Vorstellung, dass die im Süden ankommen an so einem Strand und dann hat jeder so seinen eigenen Stuhl und so und dann irgendwie Ibiza. Spring Break ist vor. Ja genau, so Ibiza, alle haben so eine Kette und die ganzen Hintergründe, die kennen sie so. Und so einen Zunraum und denkt, was haben die da für sehr viel Spaß. Leute, Süden ist nur einmal im Jahr, Süden, Süden. Ist zwar nur einmal im Jahr, aber dafür ein halbes Jahr. Ja, stimmt. Ja. Ich hoffe, sie kommen zurück. Ja, ich auch. Also meldet euch mal, schreibt eine Karte oder so. Wäre das eigentlich mal eine gute Kurzgeschichte oder so, als die Enten nicht mehr zurückkamen. So jedes Jahr fliegen die Enten in den Süden, dann kommen sie zurück, nur eines Jahr sind sie einfach nicht da und alle stehen so vor der Tür und so mit ihrer grossen Welcome Back. Papa, kannst du mir irgendwie fröhlichere Gute-Nacht-Geschichten vorlesen? Nee, also das hat ja... Weil die, die du schreibst, die sind irgendwie so, nur so trist. Naja, aber, naja, es ist ja der Moment, wo die Geschichte losgeht. Kannst du nicht nochmal, wer hat den Mauern auf den Kopf gemacht, vorlesen? Nee, das ist doch Quatsch, das ist doch kein echter emotionaler Kern in der Geschichte. Okay, dann liess, warum die Vögel nicht, das ist ja, in dem die Vögel nie zurückkamen. Und alle Leute standen auf dem Marktplatz mit grossen Bannern auf den Stand, willkommen zurück. Der ortsansässige Bäcker hatte extra ein besonders hartes Brot gebacken. Aber Papa, lass ich mal riechen. Und wie? N Marktplatz. Naja, aber das brauche ich, damit das dramaturgisch so ein bisschen besser funktioniert. Ich habe das Gefühl, du ordnest alles über diese Idee. Und die grosse Uhr auf dem Marktplatz, auf dem normalerweise jedes Jahr runtergezählt wird, bis die Enten wieder zurückkamen, wurde aufgebaut und mit dicken Lichtstrahlern angestrahlt.
Und nach einiger Zeit, in der alle Besucher sich mit heissem Glühwein die Bäuche gewärmt hatten, fing der Bürgermeister feierlich an zu zählen.
30, 29, 28!
Du kannst bei drei anfangen, weil da wissen alle Leute, das war wirklich über 30.
Das ist eben eine wichtige Sache für den Ort, dass die Endliste reinkommt.
Ja, aber das ist für die ja so, dass man nicht weiterliest.
Und auf jeder Seite hast du so eine grosse, ausgemalte Ziffer. Ja, ich musste ein bisschen die Seiten vollkriegen. Ja, aber das merkt man halt so. Fünfundzwanzig, vierundzwanzig, dreihundzwanzig, vierundzwanzig, dreiundzwanzig, zweiundzwanzig, einundzwanzig, wach auf! Hey, das ist die Nachgeschichte! Zwanzig, du weißt ja gar nicht, was passiert! Ich hab so gut geschlafen! Neunz! Und wie die Geschichte weitergeht, das erfahrt ihr in der nächsten Folge. What? Das Podcast-UFO. Wirklich? Hoffentlich erfahren wir, wie es weitergeht. Hoffentlich vergessen wir nicht, dass wir da unsere Geschichte aufgemacht haben. Hoffentlich denken wir da dran, wie es weitergeht. Ja, genau wie die Enten müssen auch wir weiterziehen. In den Süden. Auch wir sind nur hier kurz willkommen. Wir machen den Podcast auf Deutsch und auf Spanisch. Und dafür müssen wir jetzt in den Süden fliegen. Tres, du, uno, adios. Adios. Hasta luego. Bis nächste Woche, macht's gut, haut rein, wir heben. Na blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablab I was a worst bird.